foreign
[Music]
I am Noah this is my girlfriend this is
my best friend my man how long have you
two been dated just over four months
like a month give or take we met at a
party yeah and I was like I'm going to
introduce myself she slid in the DM and
she's what she doesn't want to say later
on in the night ideas
imagine trying to make it past like you
had games imagine damn that [ __ ] looks
cute over there
I got them
oh that guy called her out shout outs to
him
[Music]
where do you want to start both these
girls give me freaky Vibes oh yeah
she gives me like uh
choke me in the back of a pickup truck
while it's raining outside then drive me
through the mud kind of Vibes and the
black girl gives me like
I'll let you grab my hair
[Laughter]
if you guys don't oh man black women
refuse to let anybody grab their hair
okay you can pull my [ __ ] and so if you
meet a black woman who lets you grab
their hair they really about it and
that's game that's game whenever you go
lift a [ __ ] and you're a black
woman and you go [ __ ]
you can grab my hair yeah
listen I can honestly say all the times
I've been with a black woman and let it
reach for the hair I think me like five
percent of the time they've allowed me
to pull on that [ __ ] black women don't
care what kind of hair they got
extensions no extensions natural I
understand I'm not your man but if she
lets you do it God damn she freaking
freaky I know that Sophia is really into
fan fiction here's her Library oh no
it's all Harry Styles fan fiction this
is gonna make me sick to my stomach no
it's not oh
he grabs my waist aggressively the way
his lips touch my body and His Hands
squeezed anything from thighs to hips to
ass and to my breasts that he could so
perfectly fit into his large rough hands
deaf women
what is that creepy
writing about fantasies that you have
with some dude you don't know
I don't think it is that's the whole
point of fantasizing about someone
whether you write it down or you think
about it in your head the thoughts are
there
I agree okay lyric logic
impeccable
if I knew somebody was recording
themselves talking about the fantasies
of somebody they didn't know I'm like
that [ __ ] is crazy
something about materializing your
fantasy into writing or video evidence
for some reason for me in my head it'll
just looks sus hey as long as you don't
act upon it that's what you said watch
me you don't like one if you're jealous
as long as you don't map on it it's not
real right you can write about it you
don't act on it it's not real I agree so
none of this is real but if you start
writing it and you start recording it
then it's real [ __ ] it's literally real
yeah because you didn't do anything you
didn't act up on it that's not what
acting upon it is if I write about
suicide or if I write about if I
actually do it it's two different things
there's levels to this [ __ ] it's writing
an act I wouldn't say acting upon it
that's not what I would say you you did
an action but it was not upon what you
thought okay you just wrote it I could
see to you I could see to you I agree
with that even if I agree with that I
still think it's weird to record
I don't think I don't think it's the
same thing as going up and then saying
to somebody I want to [ __ ] you I want to
[ __ ] you I don't I don't think it's
weird I don't think it's weird it's just
it's only weird it's only weird because
it's sex but all the Harry Potters
that's pretty much fiction that a person
matter relies in but we're just weird
about it because it's sex no no it's not
weird because it's sex it's weird
because it's directed at somebody
yeah it's your fantasy with somebody
it's not the same thing Harry Potter's a
fictional character if you have a fan
fiction about fictional characters
different if somebody's writing some
[ __ ] about you talk about how much they
want to bang you and they've been
writing that in the recording that and
you found out you'd feel weird about it
yeah I feel like um
and then I found out about it I was like
that [ __ ] was weird it's just because
when they think about it you can't find
out but hold on but there's a bunch of
[ __ ] that's been having fan
fiction about you I know I know and if I
found out they had it I'm like you a
weird [ __ ] is it not you
wouldn't if somebody told you man hey I
had a fan fiction about you
I have like pause but someone said I had
fantasies about you
you wouldn't be weirded out if they
can't even told you that no
what if they started describing exactly
what happens when they financially they
do to you
I didn't ask what did they tell you they
won't be able to why because I told them
no
what you mean no you gotta punch your
ears like
you damn well know I can't do that
she damn well know
stop acting now what if you're loving
fans is showing you how much they care
about you
you know damn well I could do that don't
act like you don't know you know I could
do that in a minute
in a [ __ ] Jiffy why would you do that
though I wanna I don't want to hear it
that's your thoughts but why don't you
want to hear it it's fine
that's for a little secret garden I
didn't ask I'm cool I'm not knowing all
that [ __ ] that's fine are you saying you
don't want to hear it because you think
it's weird no I just don't need to hear
it why would you need to hear it I don't
wanna
I don't want to hear that [ __ ] no I'm
not
it's not weird it's normal I don't want
to hear it it's normally here it's
normal it's like
taking a dookie
taking a dookies normal take it I want
to get in front of other people is
different no but I don't want to hear
you take a dookie I don't necessarily
hear you from the from the toilet but
that's my whole point
I'm not weird about it I don't want to
hear that I'm chilling I'm a phone and I
hear
[Music]
is she just going off she don't even
care that I'm around no that's weird
that's weird to me that's fine go do
that over there I know what happened
it's not weird
that's the only private that's your [ __ ]
but it's not because that's literally
your shot because it's literally [ __ ]
but no that's weird but hey hey hey we
come from two different shade of
thoughts we don't want to hear it but he
don't think it's weird I do what do you
guys think of it it's your thing but
it's like I understand someone that
thinks it's weird I don't think it's
weird photos go down here to the
recently deleted and I'm saying I'm
seeing 23 here
why don't you delete these delete what
these are cute these are cute wholesome
individual I would say she's very
wholesome yes he stops only briefly
removing his thumb from my [ __ ] and
slipping two fingers of the same hand
inside of me oh my God this [ __ ]
code reading
she wrote that's weird
but okay if the [ __ ] is
[ __ ] is finding that you're
writing some [ __ ] about some other [ __ ]
and then you keep on reading keep on
reading keep on reading obviously this
[ __ ] hurt but you keep on
reading that's the me
there's something intensive about that
I'm pretty sure the producer just tell
him to kept reading sure because this is
where the meters and this [ __ ]
the cut producer yeah they like that but
I also feel like you have an extremely
sex positive attitude towards everything
because like that's even your podcast
that's your thing you have to also
recognize your perspective on things is
not the normal one that most people have
do you recognize that sure right so even
you like how you feel about a lot of
this stuff that's a very Progressive
take which I'm not mad at that sure yeah
so yeah is is is obsessing over somebody
else's if you have a partner and you
find out that they're obsessing over
somebody and then writing fan fiction
about them and how they want to
fantasize do you not think you know what
you're right but in a relationship yeah
right in a relationship I think that I
could see a lot of people finding out
that their partners are it's one thing
if you have a crush on Chris Brown
that's my celebrity crush if you're
writing whole novels about how basically
you want to [ __ ] Chris Brown because
that's all about Harry Styles apparently
foreign
you got like 50 [ __ ] scenarios that
you wrote about [ __ ] a celebrity
[ __ ] and then you're like [ __ ] I
bought tickets front row seats to go see
that
hey look I'm not jealous you know me I'm
chill about everything yeah
yeah if my girl told me after writing 50
scenarios that she trying to go see this
[ __ ] front row I don't know to
me that's I can understand without yeah
that's me I'm the weirdo I'm the winner
I wouldn't Buzz because I understand
that there's nothing I could do if you
want to like you go to Aristotle and you
get you come you come to this dude and
then you want to reenact them 50 shits
them 50 shits of whatever I can't do
nothing about that you're gonna go about
that and do that the first thing what
I'm saying so I don't think I can think
of too many women who would feel
extremely comfortable by the fact that I
was writing a bunch of scenarios about
me [ __ ] some celebrity I don't think
I know any woman who would feel really
down with that no I'm not saying they're
both centered over there it's okay when
a woman do it you're creepy if you write
scenarios about how you're gonna [ __ ]
other women you're [ __ ] creepy but
that's actually what I was gonna bring
up earlier is like fan fiction come from
I think a woman is like yeah much more
respectable because I think part of it
is like we expect men to try to act on
it because some men have tried in a
weird way or an aggressive tone maybe
that's the reason why I don't know but I
know me if I was running that kind of
[ __ ] about women that my girl found out
she probably feel weird about it yeah
definitely she's looking and I don't
know too many people who would have a
take where they'd be that open to it I
am out of that yeah yeah you're right he
stops only briefly removing his thumb
from my [ __ ] and slipping two fingers of
the same hand inside of me hot breath
Fanning against my [ __ ] he rasply
murmurs Beg For It princess oh my God
okay
I don't remember that basket
she wrote 50 of them she might not
really remember it
you know she probably feels embarrassed
right now
that's just it's that's what it is and I
understand I I I sympathize yeah because
I got notes on my phone about different
things or different thoughts I had if
they were to be read out loud I'd
probably be really bothered yeah yeah
her dad was telling me she had a big cut
out of Harry Styles life size what did
you used to do with that life-size
cutout Sophia
you know what the [ __ ] she did
that's that's
flick the bean camera flick the bean
go through his text messages and then
put my name and then see what he'd be
saying about me he has a lot of messages
that he needs to respond to
me so true I saw a text message to his
dad he said yo I'm gonna bring Garo he
said cool that's it that's it
search if there's a [ __ ] somewhere
we need some spices we need some spice
yeah he's wanting the second couple way
too boring you thought he's kind of
frustrated yeah that's why he's been
focusing on his Harry Styles jealous
yeah oh my gosh she looks so different
without a beard
sir keep that beard on that's most
people that's most people when you shave
your [ __ ] off hey hey hey hey keep that
beard off that's every man because the
more we see of you the more ugly we
realize you are
hold up you got cash yet oh no he has he
has venmo
a little 13 I can get a little coffee
after this yep
so I want to know how John's Mom feels
about me so I'm texting her and asking
her for advice on buying a ring oh gosh
she's gonna freak out I've been thinking
about this for a while I think
on one of those kind of answers
don't test [ __ ]
if you get what you didn't think you got
you done deserved it
you tested you will get if [ __ ] gets
awkward
that's on you that's not on the mom
that's not on him that's on you and if
he never told you about how his mom was
feeling about you he was trying to
protect you about that [ __ ]
Mama Knows Best not all the time but
here you go I want to start licking for
engagement rings what do you think
oh his mom texted back that's super
exciting how many have you been dating a
year
she said that yeah oh no maybe she was
super sarcastic oh that's super exciting
how long you've been dating a year
ah you know it's fixed you don't know
but yeah maybe she's super excited
really taking it seriously oh John you
can come back in
[Music]
oh she's still typing now yeah well how
was that it's fun I thought that he'd be
talking about me more in the text
messages I'm like does he use code names
like a code g the only thing that I'm
super concerned with is how my mom's
feeling now actually I'm kind of glad
that about how she took it she he
doesn't even care about Harry Styles
that's what we think when he gets back
home [ __ ] eat that [ __ ] right now and
I'm selling those tickets we bought for
that [ __ ] bro and you know he's
not he doesn't try to make that engine
that's the story somebody told me what
that they were dating somebody and then
they went to a concert for the weekend
and they texted the girl after this
concert she wouldn't respond tasted her
didn't hear from her until the next day
and then he found out from somebody that
she went back home with the weekend
because he picked her out of the crowd
um
what happened to somebody yeah it
happens I mean every time you're in a
new city he with a new girl
for the weekend
the Harry Styles fan fiction stuff is
like
I hope you know I don't think you read
that anymore oh really you like the
dirtiest ones yeah the kinky ones like
the stories of it um the story
[Music]
man but you know what I also don't know
much about fan fiction so I don't know
the world I don't know why people write
these I don't understand the whole
mindset beside it so you know I'm I'm
saying all this as an outsider who's
just like what's going on
but it's interesting stuff
when I found out you were doing fan
fictions about me I just I freaked out
so I know there's some fan fiction about
you yeah you're on Discord uh I'm not
let me just wait at the moment [ __ ] you
man
um but yeah oh some something to learn
about I guess what do you know about fan
fiction I have a sister so
she's a big geek
shout out my sister
what up
putting on blast like this she knows
I ain't got no problem with Nerds and
Geeks and fanfiction and [ __ ] like I
don't even think fan fiction is a nerd
or geek
it's sort of geeky and Nerdy
I think it's just an obsessive thing and
generally speaking so the most obsessive
people I know are not Geeks and darts no
no I feel like fan fiction is like a wet
pad have you ever heard of Wattpad no
some kind of app or anything like that
where basically it's exclusively fan
fiction it's like dominated by women
yeah I know what that is yeah yeah I
don't think that's a North I think I
just look at women that's the sort of
nerd thing that's a sort of there's some
nerd thing that's really like women are
really on some other thing oh what the
most the people that are more like like
you said what about theirs the people
that are more having a tendency to have
a fiction on something the fixation on
something they're not nerds all right so
I'm not going to be dressed like a big
old pop Pokemon no for a whole week
nerdness implies some some form of
uncoolness
that's what it implies that's that's the
way it's always been used it's always
been pejorative fair I don't think women
women in their fan fiction is not seen
as a pejorative thing okay but you
thought it was weird so it's weird in
some sense I think it's weird my whole
point is ladies can go say like yeah I
have a fan fiction about Harry Styles
and everyone's just like okay you get
what I'm saying yeah you get what I'm
saying like they can openly give me
about their wet past stuff but nobody
cares you want to talk about nerd [ __ ]
anime's nerd [ __ ] yeah those are dragons
nurture manga snort [ __ ]
you you get judged like [ __ ] I'm
judging you right now yay I know I've
been getting that [ __ ] I know so I mean
I think that's like the big thing but
yeah it's definitely from the obsess
over I think that's definitely like a
female thing for sure sure because yeah
any dude who writes fan fiction that's
your manifest
so I'm looking at you like you crazy bro
dudes who have fan fictions or just
murderers and waiting
that's what we think that's what you
think
yes yes something was talking about like
Ryan like waxing on poetically about
about to penetrate the
um [ __ ] Taylor Swift
he's getting put on a watch list yeah
definitely he's flagged
flagged
the flag I'm just imagining I think it
would be really weird to read up about
that kind of stuff my pulsating penis
and hey
that's weird
[Music]
you really look like a positive penis
right now